>>Male Presenter: Thanks for comin' today.
Appreciate it.
This is, again, another, I think, very powerful
session in terms of our inaugural At Google
Talks speaking series.
It's a perfect movie day.
So it seems highly appropriate to have a man
who revolutionized the theater experience
join us this morning.
From my seat at least, the Alamo Drafthouse
took a concept that we all accepted as good
enough and reinvented it so that it made everything
else at that point seem obsolete.
Sound familiar?
Maybe like Apple or Google?
Gmail or Maps or Offers or Apps?
So if a good movie starts with a good script,
then let me offer the following scene.
The desert spit a dry wind.
The sun set.
A star fell.
Somewhere in the hills, a curtain rose, and
on the screen it read "Once upon a time, a
movie palace died.
And decayed into a square, stale and routine
annoyance devoid of the joy your parents felt.
Mesmerized under a flickering light.
With sweaty palms and the sticky sweetness
of fountain soda through a squeaking straw.
Then a stranger appeared.
He looked at the audience and said 'No. no
more compromises.
No interference.
Just purity of essence.
And maybe some beer.
Nachos.
T-shirts in the lobby.'"
I welcome that man to the house today.
The man who dreamt, drafted, and directed,
a rebirth in the theater experience.
Tim League.
The Alamo Drafthouse.
>>Tim: Hey!
[cheers and applause]
>>Tim: I'm sorry if I slouch.
I have kind of bad posture.
My dad has bad posture.
It's genetic.
So just pretend like I'm standing straight.
'Cause eventually I'm gonna slump forward
a little bit.
So anyway, I think, one of, I'm feeding back
Should I?
[microphone noises]
>>Male Presenter: Volume a little bit?
>>Tim: There.
Is that OK?
Hey, that's me.
That's me and my wife.
So, I guess I'm gonna start just by talking
a bit about the origin of Alamo Drafthouse
Cinema.
And actually, so it starts a few years before
this picture.
This picture was taken during Week one of
construction in 1996 when we were building
our first theater on Colorado Street here
in town.
We were 26 years old and we had just moved
to town.
But I wanna back up a little bit and talk
about what brought me to the path of opening
up a movie theater with my wife.
And not wearing a shirt.
I should probably have a more respectable
slide to start things off.
[laughter]
But, I think it starts off when I was actually
in high school.
I think a lot of people that are probably
in this room had the same situation.
Where you're good in math, or you're good
in science, and then you take a certain career
path.
And it puts you into an engineering, comp
sci, technical background.
Without any really forethought.
And what it did for me was that, it set me
on a career path that I hadn't thought about
it.
It set me the first step of moving into a
career that I could have possibly retired
from without any forethought whatsoever.
So go ahead and cue the next slide.
I ended up taking a job with Shell Oil.
Out of college.
I got a mechanical engineering degree at Rice
University.
Again, just, high school math.
Yeah.
Hey.
Go Owls.
[laughter]
And so I worked as a facilities engineer which
meant I was three days out in the field doing
maximization, optimization of oil field equipment
from pump to pipeline.
That was my role for an oil field in Los Angeles.
Southern Los Angeles.
In Yorba Linda actually.
Home of Richard Milhous Nixon.
For those who are fans of the man.
[one audience member claps]
And the first day that I got onto the job
at Shell, I went through my employee training.
They gave me the handbook.
And they said "OK, you're about ready to work.
But one more thing.
You gotta go down to the basement and pick
up your art."
And I said "Oh, OK.
I don't even know what that statement means."
So I went to the basement and they had this
vast warehouse of about 5,000 oil paintings
of either landscapes or oil derricks.
I think that way, or flowers.
Flowers, oil derricks, or landscapes.
And so you're supposed to pick out the three
that you liked best for the three walls that
didn't have a window.
And that was how you decorated your office.
And that's how everybody decorated their office.
And that was such a alien and disturbing concept
to me that I knew right there that I somehow,
when I was back in high school and scored
well in math that I had made some sort of
catastrophic error in judgment.
To land me at this spot.
So I opted for an exit strategy.
I worked at Shell for a couple years.
Never stopped living like a student.
So I just amassed every dime that I made and
I knew that I was gonna do something else.
I wasn't exactly sure what I was gonna do.
So go to the next slide.
So on my way to work, was this 1947 single
screen art deco theater.
And one day I saw a "for lease" sign, and
I was on my way to work.
So, "For Lease" sign and then over the weekend
had a casual conversation with a couple friends
over some beers at a bar.
And then on Monday I went ahead and signed
the lease to open up the Tejon Theater.
With really, it's a completely, it's a decisions
that I made, I was 23 years old at the time.
And it was a decision of a 23 year old.
I was stupid.
And I completely inexperienced and way, way,
way out of my depth to try to do something
like this.
But, you know, I think about it now and I
don't think it's actually that much of a mistake,
in a way.
Because I did go through the analysis of OK,
worst case scenario, what's going to happen.
Worst case scenario is, I can go back to my
job.
I can find another job with another oil company
or another engineering form.
I'll lose the 50,000 dollars or so that I
had amassed at that point.
So no harm, no foul.
I was completely unencumbered.
Didn't have any family.
Just had a girlfriend who thought the idea
was absolutely stupid.
[laughter]
So, go ahead and go to the next slide.
Arrogance and ignorance.
Yes.
So that's sort of how I define those days
in Bakersfield.
So not only was that, it was actually a beautiful
theater on the inside, but it had been abandoned
for a number of years.
It was in Bakersfield.
Is anybody from Bakersfield?
Or driven?
Filled up gas in Bakersfield?
That's right, we had talked about that.
>>Male Presenter: Yes.
>>Tim: So let's talk about, top 20 markets
that you would open up your first movie theater
in.
Would Bakersfield come to mind?
>>Male Presenter: Bakersfield sucks.
>>Tim: Yeah.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: That's where I was born
and raised.
[laughter]
>>Tim: we did actually reminisce about some
of our favorite things about Bakersfield.
I think both of us could show everybody in
this room a tremendous weekend in Bakersfield.
But then, we would have shot it.
There's no, that's what you got.
Bakersfield's a good weekend time.
But.
But it was on the wrong side of the tracks
in Bakersfield also.
There were literally railroad tracks that
divided the affluent and the poor side of
Bakersfield.
And being 23 years old at the time.
And having a lot more hair.
That's me on the whatever that is, the right.
I said it doesn't matter if we put on a great
show, then the people are going to come and
they're going to overcome their prejudices
and not worry about where they're going.
That was a complete, that was a fallacy.
It just didn't work out that way.
So we opened up as a, it was a 1,000 seat
theater.
So we took out half of the seats and opened
up as a art house theater.
And most days we were hoping that nobody would
show up so that we could have a night off.
But ultimately, like one or two people.
One conscious decision would come and buy
the five dollar, seven dollar movie ticket,
would come and sort of screw up our plans
to get out of the theater.
So we ran this place for two years.
And it was a tremendous struggle.
And, it was actually kind of depressing, too.
Because we never left the building.
We didn't have enough money to live anywhere
else.
So we just built pretty much the most depressing
and squalid bedroom
[laughter]
Behind the screen of the movie theater.
So there's no windows.
And then sort of [laughs].
Yeah.
It was terrible.
And then insult to injury, the only thing
that ever worked for us is we did live music
as well.
'Cause it was a very big facility.
But the only room that was suitable for a
"Green Room" for the band was our bedroom.
[laughter]
So, you now, we'd have mostly punk and metal
shows come through town.
And you know, they wanna just live up to the
lifestyle somehow.
So the thing that they do is sort of just
semi trash our bedroom.
[laughter]
So we'd, you know, spend the night, 'cause
we didn't really have any staff.
We'd spend the night cleaning the theater.
And we'd come back.
We'd come back to this "Green Room" that smelled
like, I don't know what.
Hookers, and drugs and certainly alcohol.
So that was our life for a couple of years.
The way we ran it was, it was just the two
of us.
It was, well, it was eventually my wife.
My girlfriend was working in San Francisco.
She was a molecular biology researcher.
And also followed the science path.
And so I started this theater.
And after a month it was plain and simple
that I was so over my head that I needed help.
So I begged her to quit her job and come down
and salvage what we could out of this enterprise.
And you know, my parents were sort of pissed
off about my decision to do what I had done.
And her parents were I think, exponentially
pissed off about her decision.
[laughter]
So we had both thrown away an expensive Rice
University education and decided to do a completely
trivial and possibly hopeless exercise.
But she did it.
She quit her job.
She moved down.
And she actually did save the theater.
She got things in order.
And so the two of us would be behind the concessions
counter.
She would be selling tickets and I would be
serving popcorn and whatever.
And then when it came movie time, I would
run upstairs, start the movie, and then run
back downstairs and help sell popcorn.
But.
Thankfully there was no customers so that
system worked out.
[laughter]
Really, really well for a while.
So you know, one of the lessons there was
this importance of the location.
It's such a cliché when talking about business.
But.
It really, really is true.
So.
We knew, we knew at a certain point that we
wanted to, this was untenable.
We couldn't stay at the Tejon.
That we had to go someplace else.
And we knew when we went someplace else we
wanted to find just the right location.
So.
Go ahead to the next one.
Yeah, I mentioned that we did, the movies
really they did not work for us.
It really literally was two to ten people
for every screening.
We would only pay the bare minimum to the
film distributors.
But we did have success with concerts.
This is a shot from the second to last Ramones
tour.
So we were able to just 'cause there was no
other big venue that wanted to book that kind
of show, we were able to book lots of things
like this.
So, Tool.
The Ramones.
Pennywise played.
Los Lobos even played.
So that's the money that we amassed to get
out of Bakersfield.
Go to the next slide.
So this, yeah, I don't know, some people probably
still remember this.
This is like the seminal classic of the modern
era was Montell Jordan's "This is How We Do
It."
[laughter]
Does everybody remember that song?
It's good.
If this were a better presentation we could
all listen to the music video now.
But it's not.
We just have to imagine it in our head.
So this was, in fact, the last straw that
took us out of Bakersfield.
So we agreed to do a concert with Montell
Jordan.
And it was right when that album hit.
Right when he was at the peak of his 15 minutes.
And I mean it's, it was such a lame concert.
Because he only really had about seven songs
so the concert was, about 40 minutes long,
45 minutes long.
And he played "This is How We Do It" twice.
[laughter] It was in the middle of the set,
and then it was the encore.
It was like, oh man.
So, but, the unfortunate thing that happened
that night is there was some sort of lover's
quarrel after the show.
And somebody was driving away, and the one
of the members of that love triangle pulled
out a gun and shot the guy that was driving
away.
So he shot him and killed him.
And his car wrecked into our ticket booth.
So the next morning front page of the paper
was this car, our ticket booth, our marquees.
It was like, again, disproving the no such
thing as bad press.
It was like the worst conceivable press when
we were struggling to convince people that
it was safe to come over.
To cross the tracks and enjoy a nice movie.
Then we just knew we were already struggling.
This, we were not gonna be able to overcome
this.
So we packed everything we had.
We took the projectors, the screen, the speakers,
200 chairs, the everything.
Everything we could.
And we put it in a truck and we came to Austin.
So that's.
And that's, I guess I've got two slides where
I'm not wearing a shirt.
At least that one's small.
[laughter]
So, we came to Austin in 1996.
To start over again.
Lot of things we had done at Bakersfield were
the origins for what we were gonna try to
do at the Austin location.
And but, we were aiming a little bigger.
But the problem is, we didn't have any money.
We had about 50 to 60 thousand dollars that
we had pulled out of two years of hard scrabble
work in Bakersfield.
And that's not nearly enough.
So this is our first pace which is at 409
Colorado.
As you can see.
That's week one.
Where my wife is actually pulling out nails
from the wood that we salvage out of the building
so that we could reuse it into the building.
That kind of level of bootstrapping.
So we assembled money.
We did this through a couple of ways.
One, my wife's parents now, now wife, I made
good.
[claps] I, she was no longer my girlfriend.
Now my wife.
Her parents were still very skeptical about
the idea since we had failed miserably and
then start it again.
But they actually agreed to mortgage their
house for us.
So they gave us 125,000 dollars from a mortgage
from their house.
My parents did the same.
Sort of.
They got us about 50,000 dollars.
Did the stereotypical credit card loans.
So we got about 70 grand from a variety of
credit cards taken out on the same day.
[laughter]
And, I don't know if you can still do that.
That was a great trick back in the '90s.
[laughter]
So.
Back when you had to mail in your credit application.
And then the last one I think is the funniest
bit.
We got another 50,000 dollars from Bank of
America.
But we were so not a good credit risk.
We could not get a loan under any sort of
normal circumstances.
But that year and that year alone in the history
of Bank of America, they had this thing called
"Invest in America" loan.
Which was a 50,000 dollar small business start
up.
One page form.
You just signed it and you basically got approval
that day from the bank.
And so we got 50,000 dollars from Bank of
America.
But apparently we were of the five percent
that paid back that loan.
At any time.
So it was a tremendously abused loan that
will never be seen again for Bank of America.
But anyway, that's what we got.
We had about 275,000 dollars.
And in that space, Karrie and I built it ourselves.
We had one guy that helped us with some of
the more complicated things and things that
we weren't allowed.
Like setting the air conditioning units.
And getting the plumbing inspections.
We did a lot of the rough plumbing and the
rough electrical.
But we did everything else ourselves.
So it was new electrical.
New utility service in the alley.
Built the kitchen.
Built the restrooms.
Built the risers.
Built the projector room.
All for about 200,000 dollars.
Which, I don't know how that, I don't know,
it's inconceivable to me, this day.
We did a minor renovation of the lobby at
Village recently.
That cost 300,000 dollars.
So I don't.
it was nothing.
So I don't know.
We really, really, really scraped.
And did all of the work ourselves.
The problem there, though, is it left us,
end of the day, we had about 25,000 dollars
for working capital to start the business.
Which, if the business had failed, in the
first month, then it would have, we wouldn't
have known what to do.
We would have been crying back to our parents
again.
To invest bad money after, good money after
bad.
So we'll go ahead and go to the next slide.
So, that's the, I guess there's a little bit
of a segue here.
[laughter] but that's the origin of the Alamo.
And how we got to the first location.
And I do think that one of the, when I'm talking
to people that are entrepreneurs, people who
are thinking about doing their own business.
What I mentioned earlier about really doing
a hard assessment of what is the worst case
scenario and can you be comfortable with the
worst case scenario is a very valuable exercise.
And I think even when we were doing the theater
in Austin, not just the Bakersfield theater.
We did that exercise again.
And we knew that we were taking this money
from our parents.
But we had assured them that if this time
it didn't work, that we would go back into
engineering, research, and work out a payment
plan and get them their money back.
So even then it really wasn't the end of the
world.
But we felt like it was worth it to risk it.
Because by that hard scrabble work for two
years and ultimately failing in Bakersfield,
we learned a lot of things.
We learned how to be very, very frugal.
We knew exactly where every dime was in our
organization.
And we learned how to just do things ourselves.
And find a cheaper alternate route.
Ultimately, obviously, we've grown in size.
We now have ten locations.
We've got two under construction.
We do have plans to open in some other cities.
We should be making an announcement about
New York and San Francisco soon.
Relatively soon.
We have spots identified.
And hopefully within, by the first couple
weeks in January we can make that public.
The idea is just to sort of grow the concept
and experience of what we've been trying to
do here in Austin.
To other cities that don't have it.
I guess I'll go into what I think some of
the.
"Core values" is one of those terms.
Like mission statement.
Where some people sort of frown on it.
And I, uh, well we went through an exercise
to go through it.
And I've become comfortable with what previously
might have been sort of a questionable idea.
Those words sometimes, you know they still
actually sort of prickle a little bit at the
base of my spine.
But I do think it's really, really important
to know you know, who you are or why you're
doing what you're doing.
And what's important to you.
So we went through a process and came up with
I think some core values.
So I'm gonna cycle through some of those real
quick.
[pause as he shows the slides]
Here we go.
Ah, there we go.
Fun Experts.
This is Zack Carlson who works for us.
And I'm not sure what it is.
I hope that that's not a baby.
I don't know what that is [laughter] I don't
know.
Let's just pretend it's a piece of meat.
Anyway, but that's Zack Carlson.
So he's one of the guys that has joined the
programming department at the Alamo.
And, the way he came to the company is, he
volunteered to because he was such a movie
fan to join us on our nationwide outdoor movie
screening tour.
He has worked at a video store.
Scarecrow Video up in Seattle.
Which is the biggest video store in the world.
It employs a lot of obsessive compulsives
like Zack.
[laughter]
And recently he actually published a book
called "Destroy All Movies" which is a compendium
of every single appearance of a punk rock
character in cinema from 1978 to 1990.
It's 5,000 reviews of movies.
With in depth interviews with the Titans of
punk rock on film.
So he's a guy that, there is no other job
for him.
He has to be programming at the Alamo Drafthouse.
Because there's no other life skills that
he's got other than
[laughter]
the, just the sheer unadulterated joy and
love of kinda weird cinema.
So, we have a programming, creative office
of about 15 people.
A lot of them, they're not necessarily like
Zack.
But I think we try to hire obsessive movie
fans.
Oh, before I talk about my mom.
That's my mom.
The Fun Experts.
I wanna explain what that meant.
We do a, a eight day film festival in the
fall.
Of horror, science fiction movies called Fantastic
Fest.
We had a Spanish filmmaker.
Not even a native speaker come up to me and
he's been at the festival every year since
his first feature debuted in 2007.
He's come back to the festival just as a fan
every year since.
He said "Tim, I've figured it out.
You guys are experts in the under-appreciated
art of having fun."
So I was like, you know what, I'm gonna turn
that into a slide in a PowerPoint presentation.
Alright, on to my mom.
So this is my mom.
And it's the slide is actually perfectly positioned.
She's just staring at me, right.
Maybe not judging me.
Maybe a little judging me.
I'm not sure.
But I use my mom as a barometer.
Like a lot of people misunderstand the identity
of the Alamo.
And thing that it's just a, sometimes it'
s just a cult movie place.
Or that's what we're all about.
But I, for me, it's, the idea of inclusivity.
I want my mom to be comfortable every time
she comes to the theater.
So it means, death metal shouldn't be playing
on the radio at the box office.
And even if our staff has more tattoos and
piercings than she's normally used to, they
should also have a smile and be really nice
and friendly to her.
That's just in general.
She's me, she's my sort of rudder in making
sure the business is still on track in that
regard.
We also, we're, I guess, always trying to
do something a little bit better.
This is a guy we just recently brought on.
Bill Norris.
He's sort of the Austin celebrity bartender.
But he's now the Director of Beverage for
Alamo Drafthouse.
He was reaching a point in his career where
he's, like myself, early 40s. but he was closing
down bars at two o'clock in the morning.
But I think I caught him at a good time.
Where he was just weary at where he was.
He's built a great reputation for being exceptional.
He hates the word mixologist.
Bartender.
And was ready to take a new step.
So he came on with us and his job now is just
to make sure that every beverage that we serve
is awesome and he also runs the cocktail program
at Highball.
And we're opening up a tequila bar as part
of our new Slaughter Lane down on South Mopac.
And a couple other things for us.
But I think the idea is that where we recognize,
well maybe we're not doing this quite well
enough.
Or there's other people that impress us.
So we want to always try to surpass them by
bringing in people and lending focus to areas
where there's room for improvement.
'Cause there's always room for improvement.
As you guys know at Google, everything changes
in the technology side of things just way
too fast.
And we have to, we feel like we have to stay
on top of the curve.
I'm sure that you guys had that pressing desire
to stay on top of the curve as well.
Or maybe you're just setting the curve I don't
know.
Whatever.
But anyway.
So.
Oh, go ahead and go to the next one.
I was struggling for a picture when I was
putting this together.
I actually, I'm gonna go ahead and brave it
and say that I don't like Stevie Ray Vaughn.
I sometimes, I should stop saying it because
most of the time it creates awkwardness because
he's such an iconic figure in this town.
But anyway.
He is an iconic figure in this town.
But that has nothing to do with what our aspect
of community is.
We like to think, do you have a question about
Stevie Ray Vaughn?
[audience member speaks off mic]
>>Tim: I do.
I do like that building.
Our law firm is there.
But I like it because every time I go up there
it reminds me of that "My Neighbor Totoro",
that Miyazaki movie.
I don't know.
So.
I think it's the most beautiful mov-, uh,
building, in downtown.
So, sure, I'm a fan.
Alright.
I'll crop out Stevie Ray and I'll just put
[laughter]
The tower.
So, we like to think of ourselves as a neighborhood
movie theater.
And I think it happened inadvertently when
we weren't thinking about it . when it was
just, when we literally were a mom and pop
theater back in Bakersfield and the 409 Colorado
space.
It was my wife and I. we were there every
day.
We did the same thing we were doing in Bakersfield.
But we had a small staff.
But we knew all of our regular customers.
We introduced the shows personally.
We answered our customer feedback personally.
And I think that just sorta set the tone.
And now as we're expanding we're trying to
make sure that that never gets lost.
Both the idea of giving back to the community,
of being available to the community for nonprofit
events and fundraisers.
But then also having the sense that we are
a part of and responsible to the neighborhood
that's immediately around us.
And then, the last one.
Is, that we wanna be credible.
And I bring this up, not that like this gang
of dudes is not credible.
But.
There was a period in time where I had stepped
away from the Alamo Drafthouse to a certain
extent.
We had started a franchise company.
But really had no concept of what that meant
and what the obligations to the people that
we were working with in a franchise relationship,
what that was.
So we were again, in over our head.
So we decided to ostensibly sell the business.
So back about six years ago we sold Alamo
Drafthouse.
But retained ownership of the theaters in
the town.
The Village.
South Lamar.
And the Downtown Theater.
And just focused our energies on those theaters.
And that's when we really got a sense of what
the brand was and some of our specialty programming
really grew in those years.
And that's when we started the festival.
At the same time, that other company was developing
other locations.
And our vision was starting to spread.
Like there was an Alamo Drafthouse that we
shepherded that was this.
There was an Alamo Drafthouse that we didn't
have any involvement with, this.
We were both, just fighting.
And it became worse and worse and worse and
worse.
And then ultimately we both realized that
the best thing to do would be to shake hands,
settle our differences, and smash everything
back together.
So there was one vision, one brand, one identity.
And that's, that happened about a year and
three months ago.
And it's been actually great.
But I bring up this slide.
And I probably can't do this in any internal
Alamo talks along this.
I'll have to change the slide out.
But one of the things that drove me crazy
during that period was this issue of credibility.
Whereas we had invested in guys like Zack
Carlson and really hardcore obsessive movie
guys, the other locations had not.
And so it was evident in some of the programming.
And this is the one that was almost like that
last straw for me.
There was an event that we'd been doing for
years and years and years.
Called Spaghetti Western, Spaghetti Feast.
Where classic spaghetti westerns, with all
you can eat spaghetti.
Very simple, very silly concept.
But it always worked.
At least for the non-obscure spaghetti westerns.
So, it was one of the outside of Austin locations
put together a show called Spaghetti Western,
Spaghetti Feast, with Young Guns.
I said, not on my watch is that ever gonna
happen ever again.
Because that, my friends, is not a spaghetti
western.
So anyway, that's, basically what I'm trying
to say with a long and rambly story is that
it's very important that if we're gonna put
our name on something that somebody can't
you know, sneer at us.
And think that we don't get it.
So, the decisions, in terms of what we do
and how we do it, we have to be able to stand
behind those decisions.
So that's, that's it for the.
Yeah, that's it for our quote unquote core
values.
And I think the last thing I wanna do is just
run through a couple of the folks on the Alamo
team.
I think that first slide is probably that
Zack Carlson slide again.
So if it is we'll cycle past him 'cause you've
already met Zack.
No!
I think I might have already taken him out.
Sorry to say no like that.
>>Male Presenter: [laughs]
>>Tim: so we do have a big creative staff.
This is Henry Mazza.
Who runs the creative department.
He runs all the action packed stuff and the
sing-alongs.
Quote-alongs.
And also kinda oversees a lot of the programming
at the Highball as well.
So Henry started kind of as a food runner.
Kind of lowest on the totem pole.
Moved to waiter.
And then at a certain point we wanted to cross
train him.
Because we thought he was really clever and
fun.
Had some really good ideas.
So I was like "Hey, would you like to cross
train to be, you know, in the kitchen?"
He was like "Well, you know, actually, technically
I'd like to cross train to be an owner."
And so I thought, that's pretty good for a
24 year old kid who's been on with us for
a year as a waiter.
But ultimately I liked a lot of his ideas.
He started programming on his own.
And, hired him to be the first member of the
creative staff.
And now he oversees the group of 20.
And also is helping the other markets develop
their own creative staff under our model.
Next one.
Oh, that's Zack.
You know Zack.
We'll just move on to the next one.
This is Lars Nilsen.
And he came to the Alamo, similar way.
So we do a show every Wednesday called Weird
Wednesday.
Which is, used to be free.
Now it's a dollar or two dollars.
Screenings of 35 millimeter '70s and '80s
exploitation movies.
Kinda sleazy movies.
But it's a genre of film that I hold very
dear.
And so does Lars.
So I became friends with him just as a patron.
I used to host that show and curate the show
and pick out the movies.
And so eventually, this is a long time ago,
this is 11 years ago.
He would start bringing VHS tapes to the theater
for the pre-show that he had made on his own.
So "Hey Tim, this is a collection of clips
that I think really suits the movie.
And this is what you should probably play
for this."
I was like "Oh, OK.
This is great."
So we'd do that for a few months and then
I passed the reins.
He started programming the series.
And then he started introducing all the shows.
And then a friend of mine had to tell me,
that, point out, that Lars actually, in fact,
was working for me but I wasn't paying him
anything.
[laughter]
So I rectified that.
He's the guy that was the first employee to
handle the Alamo pre-show which is the video
montage of clips that happens before the movie.
We have a full time staff employed that does
that work for us.
So no advertisements, as one of our, it's
not really a core value.
But it's what we do at the theater.
And not only that, not only do we ignore the
revenue stream of the advertisements.
We go deeper in the hole by having a full
time staff in order to create that content.
So.
[laughter]
Go ahead.
Ah, this is Andrew McEthron.
Who was a college student that I met back
in 1999.
He was the technical, well at the time he
was a college student he was a technical coordinator
for South by Southwest.
He was also head of all projection for Cinemark
in the area.
And I just, I used to handle a lot of the
technical side of the projection room back
when we were a lot smaller.
And we bonded because we were able to talk
about gears and nuts and bolts and that sort
of thing.
So.
But he was working for Cinemark and they were
paying him such an abysmal wage that I said
"Wow, that's really not a lot of money.
I can give you 50 percent more if you come
work for me."
Which really wasn't a lot of money at the
time either.
But he's, he came on board.
Worked for us part time while he was in college
and has continued for the last eight years
after college.
Oversees.
He was computer science.
So he did database development for South by
Southwest.
So he handles all of our IT execution as well
as the projection side.
He's got a team under him now.
Next one.
And this is another interesting obsessive
compulsive orphan that's on our team.
Justin moved down, he, I knew him because
we're a, we collect old film.
Justin was a 23 year old film collector in
Kansas City.
He moved down to Alamo, we got him a job as
a bartender.
He was kind of a crappy bartender.
And then we moved him over to projection.
He wasn't that great at projection.
[laughter]
So we moved him over to the outdoor movie
rolling road show.
Where he proved to be not able to shine so
well.
[laughter]
Then we moved him over to venue rental to
see if he could do something there and, quickly
realized that that wasn't his calling either.
[laughter]
So, on his fifth shot, we moved him into taking
over Mondo.
Which is our sort of boutique poster company.
And that's where we finally found a spot,
where this is the guy.
He dug in and he created something really
special that wasn't part of the company before.
So I don't know how many people know about
Mondo.
But it's they're highly sought after limited
edition art posters for movies.
You can see a few behind him in the background
there.
Or nerdy properties for the most part.
It's been a huge year for Mondo.
There's been articles about them in the New
York Times and Wall Street Journal.
They've also been the only company outside
of the studio system that has their posters
now archived at the American, what, the, uh,
MPA.
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences.
So we're, every single Mondo poster is archived.
Go on to the next one.
And this is Mike.
Mike came to us, he was the head of operations
for all of Trudy's.
He came to us from Trudy's.
What's important, I talked a lot about the
passion.
But this goes back to the early lessons of
the first days.
Having a very clear eye on what the numbers
are.
So Mike does a lot of statistical analysis.
We look at our revenue numbers and our expense
numbers on a daily basis.
And we also look at our customer satisfaction
numbers.
Our sort of, net promoter score.
And that's, it's those indices of how well
we're doing that everybody in the company
is bonused by.
The managers know that they have to make sure,
make sure that our guests are happy and that
they come back and they wanna come back or
decided to come back.
So that's the man that does that.
You know that guy already.
Yeah.
He makes really good drinks.
And then John Bullington is our head of cuisine.
He came to us from Mars Restaurant years and
years ago.
Mars, and at the time Mars was voted best
restaurant in Austin.
And we had to really convince him that moving
to a place that served pizzas and burgers
and cranked out a lot of them in a really
fast amount of time was something he wanted
to do.
But we also give him a lot of freedom to express
his sort of chef-y side of things, too.
And so I have a few slides of I think a few
things that he's done over the years.
We'll cycle through those real quick.
Oh no, I took those out.
Alright, never mind.
So, anyway, but John does these feast events.
Lord of the Rings feast event where there's
a different meal every two hours for a 12
hour experience.
[laughter]
It's a gargantuan amount of food.
The very, very first thing that he ever did
for us is, uh, he's a big fan of the movie
"Ishtar".
So he did a five course feast built around
the movie Ishtar of Moroccan food.
So every month and a half or so, we'll do
a high end food and film themed even that
John curates.
He does a lot of community outreach, too.
He brings students in to learn about the kitchen.
He does mock interviews for them.
To help with the Texas Culinary Academy.
And just is given the freedom to do some crazy
wacky things.
We'll go ahead and, the next.
The other thing that we like to do at the
Alamo is try to go over the top when we possibly
can.
This was for the premier of Iron Man.
Where it was really cute.
This guy is a guy that flies over stadiums
in a jet pack.
For whatever reason.
And that's his job.
But he was so excited about being perceived
as Iron Man that he handmade this little felt
[laughter]
Iron Man costume.
[laughs] I thought it was one of the cutest
things ever.
[laughter]
Anyway, so that's one of the things we've
done.
Go ahead to the next one.
This was an event we did for the remake of
Amityville Horror.
Ryan Reynolds was coming into town.
And so in order to get a chance to meet Ryan
Reynolds and hang out at the screening you
had to walk through the House of Flies.
So we found that you, for I don't know why,
but on the internet you can buy fly larvae
that can hatch into flies.
So I bought a box of 20,000 flies.
[laughter]
And the problem was I failed to really understand
the instructions.
I let it sit for a little bit too long before
I opened it.
And the box was like literally shaking and,
so I had, I went into this House of Flies
with an X-acto knife and I knew this was gonna
be a horrible thing.
And so I had the eye goggles on.
I had like a hoodie pulled tight.
And I sliced the box open and this wave of
flies just flew into my face.
And I had an X-acto knife and just like sort
of.
I don't know what I did.
I just started flailing and completely lacerated
my hand open.
So I just ran out of the House of Flies.
[laughter]
Bleeding and and screaming.
And but anyway.
It worked.
Eventually it worked.
So if you're gonna buy flies, I guess the
lesson here is, if you're gonna buy flies
on the internet, read the instructions as
to when they're actually going to hatch.
OK.
Go on to the next slide.
Um, this was an even for the unfortunate box
office disappointment of Nacho Libre.
Everybody was really expecting it to be awesome
after Napoleon Dynamite.
It was OK, but the studio agreed to finance
this show that we put together.
Where we brought in Lucha Libre wrestlers
from Mexico City.
Some of them midgets.
Some of them full size.
[laughter]
And so they dragged me into the ring and they
didn't speak English.
And so there I was just sort of following
along.
So "OK, so you wanna hold my arms back like
this.
OK, you're gonna hit me in the chest with
a two by four.
I've always wanted to know what that is.
How you do that trick.
'Cause it looks so convincing."
And so apparently the way that you do that
trick is, the guy holds your arms back and
the guy on the ground hits you really hard
on the chest with a two by four.
[laughs]
[laughter]
And I had this crazy like, three and a quarter
inch bruise across my chest for about two
weeks.
[laughter]
I don't know.
It was fun.
[laughter]
Oh, go ahead and go to the next one.
I don't know why, but it's Ryan Reynolds I
guess likes to come into town.
So this is again a stump for Ryan Reynolds'
"Buried."
Which came out last year.
Last year?
I think it was last year.
Yeah.
Supremely underrated movie.
I really loved this film.
And it all takes place inside of a coffin.
Ryan Reynolds is buried either in Iraq or
Afghanistan and has a phone and is trying
to find a way to get out of this box.
So we staged a contest for people to volunteer
to watch the ultimate “Buried” experience.
Where we met them at the theater, blindfolded
them, took them in a van out into the country,
where we had dug four shallow graves and built
four coffins that had LCD monitors built into
the top of them.
So it was this.
It was.
And then we buried them.
[laughter]
And then, so it was the, the screening.
Like supposed to be the ultimate "Buried"
screening.
Like, put yourself inside the movie.
[laugher]
And, so, we did that.
It was an idea.
I saw the movie at Sundance.
It was an idea that my friend and I had.
And we said, oh, there's no way this is gonna
pass legal.
But we went ahead and sent it over to the
studio.
And I don't know if legal was just, I caught
'em on a day where they were not paying attention.
But anyway, they said "Yeah.
Sure.
No problem.
Do it."
[laughter]
Provided that we assume the liability.
Which we did.
It really wasn't that dangerous.
We tested it all out.
There was airflow systems.
And there was paramedics on hand.
And we had cameras monitoring them.
So anyway.
It was a fun event.
It was good.
[audience commenting off mic]
Well, they were buried for the whole movie.
They had to watch the movie inside the coffin.
So for each of 'em were buried for 90 minutes
while they watched "Buried."
[audience laughing and chattering]
Yeah.
We made it actually extra special for them,
there was a little tube.
So when sand would come into Ryan Reynolds'
coffin we'd dump sand into their coffin.
[laughter]
Not a lot.
Just some.
To give them a taste.
But.
[laughter]
So, go ahead and move on.
The, and that, the other things we do is we
take the Alamo on the road.
We do famous movies in famous places.
We've been doing this for the last seven years.
We've done "Jaws" at Martha's Vineyard.
This is "Close Encounters" at Devils Tower.
You know "Escape from Alcatraz" on Alcatraz.
So every year we try to go crazier and crazier.
We pitched this idea.
I haven't told anybody this yet.
But one I really wanna do is a similar to
the, we did Buried, and it's like oh, what
could be even more traumatic than buried.
So what we're gonna try to do is get our insurance
carrier to cover us for the screening of watching
"Jaws" in shark-infested waters in a shark
tank.
If we can figure out how to do that.
[laughter]
So that may be part of the next road show
tour this summer.
It's been pitched.
I don't know.
We'll see.
Totally safe.
You know, we take every safety precaution
here at the Alamo.
[laughter]
Go ahead and go to the next one.
And there's John doing one of his skills at
Fantastic Fest.
I mentioned it before but this is a festival
that focuses on horror, science fiction and
fantasy.
Things that we really, that our programming
team really loves.
So John always likes to do something special
for the closing night party.
This is a 700 pound cow that he sort of butterflied
and roasted on a open fire for 22 hours.
As really sort of a visceral way to eat a
steak.
So that was, so he's carving it off for the
attendees.
And I think, we've just got a couple more
slides.
But just, we've started to branch out and
consider the Alamo as more of a entertainment
brand.
If you will.
And so we're, we've started a film distribution
company.
It's gonna be in full swing in 2012.
We're gonna try to release six new movies
and six classic old movies a year.
This is our first one that we did.
It's sort of a beta test.
It's called "Four Lions."
Ended up, TIME Magazine called it one of the
best, ten best films of the year in 2010.
We were able to get it, I think because we're
drawn to movies that we're really passionate
about but also maybe have something a little
bit wrong with them.
[laughter]
And so what's wrong about this one is that
it's jihadi suicide bomber comedy.
[laughter]
And at the time, tensions were high around
this particular issue.
So I think, even though it was directed by
really a legend of comedy in the UK, Chris
Morris, a lot of distributors that we thought
would have bought it were afraid that perhaps
a jihad would be called against them for doing
such a blasphemous thing.
It's actually in fact not blasphemous.
It's very, very respectful to the religion.
What he was trying to point out is how certain
types of oblivious youth get drawn to movements
like this in the UK.
And sort of drawing out the stupidity of the
people that would sign up to be a suicide
bomber.
So.
That's what it's about.
It's a good film.
I like it.
But, so, we're gonna pick movies that we love
and maybe movies that have some issues like
this one to push out there and try to support
and nurture in 2012.
And that brings us to the last thing.
Greg wanted me to talk a little bit about
our viral sensation this year which was a
lot of fun.
So what happened was at the Village Theater,
one of our customers was kicked out for texting.
And despite her disjointed claims and her
subsequent voicemails, she was texting in
her seat and refused to acknowledge the warning
to stop doing it.
And so our policy is to kick that person out
without a refund.
It's been a policy we've had since the very,
very early days.
It wasn't since day one, it was actually,
the policy came out when during a screening
of "Blue Velvet" at midnight at the original
location where it came, like a free Pabst
Blue Ribbon at the door.
And people just started drinking probably
too much Pabst Blue Ribbon.
It just go out, it got out of control.
It made me sick to my stomach and I was like,
this is not what I signed up for.
We don't have controls in place to take care
of these people.
And so it was after that screening that we
instituted the policy back in '97.
And we've taken it very seriously ever since.
We've kicked out a lot of people.
Probably about 100 people a year, we kick
out of the theater without a refund.
And hopefully the lesson is that they're not
welcome at the Alamo until they can change
their behavior.
And then they can, then they're a guest again.
But so this one voicemail came through.
Our manager sent it to us 'cause our voicemail
comes through Mp3.
He said "Hey, check this out, this would make
a really funny 'Don't Talk' PSA."
And we agreed and just cut something together.
We cut it to just put up on screen.
And we at the same time, when we put it up
on screen, we posted it on YouTube.
We've been doing that for the last year or
so when we do a new "Don't Talk" PSA.
We put it on YouTube as well.
So Roger Ebert I think was the first guy that
saw it.
And we had engaged in dialog with him about
digital projection 'cause he had gotten up
on a soapbox and we got, became part of that
dialog with him.
And I think he subsequently started following
our feeds.
And so he reposted it and when he did that,
it started posting at a whole bunch of other
sites and we had never been any, through anything
like this.
So it was clear that something had gone wrong.
'Cause our website was 100 percent shut down.
Like 'cause when, people were linking back
to our blog post.
So Andrew, our IT guy figured out very, very
quickly how to dynam-, to host that page in
the Cloud.
And also, yes, and get our website back.
'Cause once you know website controls everything
for us.
We, close to 70 percent of our ticket sales
are online.
So when the website goes down it's very devastating
for us.
So we got it working again and then by the
end of the day the numbers had spiked up to
two and a half million views on this clip.
And they ultimately went up to five and a
half million.
But the following day it got picked up by
some serious news outlets.
Howard Stern picked it up that day.
But the best one was Anderson Cooper.
Later that night.
So his people called us.
We got some interviews set.
And he did, kind of a interesting overview
of the piece.
And so I think we have the Anderson Cooper
clip.
Switch that over.
'Cause he not only shows the clip, but breaks
it down in a very Anderson Cooper way.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: OK.
>>Tim: He lumps on some unworthy praise but
we're gonna totally take it anyway.
>>Male Presenter: Where's my, how do we get
out of the full screen of this shortcut?
We gotta find it.
>>Male: What did you do?
>>Male Presenter: Uh, nothing.
Go ahead.
>>Tim: [chuckles]
>>Male: Well, uh, you just do.
That's the uh, full screen.
>>Male Presenter: OK.
Thank you, sir.
OK.
And I have that clip right here.
[pause]
[video clip begins]
>>Female Announcer: Well, in case you're wondering
where he is, he's on the road, so, let's see.
>>Anderson Cooper: Uh, thanks very much.
Alright, so time now for the ridiculous.
Tonight we're adding my latest source of annoyance.
People who talk and text at the movies.
And I wanna talk about one young woman in
particular.
A woman who was repeatedly warned to stop
texting during a movie in Austin, Texas.
Wouldn't stop and was promptly thrown out
of the theater.
Then she left an angry voicemail for the theater,
which is posted on its blog for your enjoyment.
>>Female Customer: Didn't know that I wasn't
supposed to text in your little crappy [bleep]
theater.
>>Anderson Cooper: Alright, did I mention
that theater is called the Alamo Drafthouse
and that they serve beer?
Well, I'm not sure if I mentioned that but
indeed, I think our texter may have partaken
a bit.
A little pre-party during the previews perhaps.
Listen to her next offense.
>>Female Customer: So excuse me for using
my phone in USA Magnited State of America.
Where you are free to text in a theater.
>>Anderson Cooper: I love living in the Magnited
States of America.
[laughter]
>>Anderson Cooper: Where you are free to text
in a theater.
Now that's a lady who knows her Constitution.
What's all that freedom jazz about if some
drunk girl can't constantly update her Facebook
status while people are trying to concentrate
on Kung Fu Panda II.
Next the lady employs something I like to
call "The Silent but Deadly" defense.
>>Female Customer: And it was on silent.
It wasn't on loud.
It wasn't bothering anybody.
You guys obviously were being [bleep] to me.
>>Anderson Cooper: I'm sorry drunk girl.
But texting in a dark movie theater is like
lighting a road flare.
People are gonna see it.
[laughter]
You might not through your beer goggles, but
everybody else will.
Drunk girl didn't give up though.
She's been hitting the law books apparently
and comes up with two more arguments for her
defense.
A combo of the "I didn't know" defense seasoned
with just a touch of the "I do it everywhere
else" defense.
>>Female Customer: I was not aware that I
couldn't text in your theater.
Alright?
I've texted in all the other theaters in Austin.
And no-one ever gave a [bleep] about what
me, I was doing with my [bleep] phone.
Alright?
>>Anderson Cooper: Now maybe she has texted
her way through every other movie theater
in Austin.
I wouldn't be surprised.
But as it turns out, this particular theater
has a well-known zero tolerance policy against
talking and cell phones.
It's kinda this theater's crusade.
And they have all kinds of creative announcements
about it.
Watch.
>>Male #1: I keep a, uh, electric cattle prod
with me.
So if I hear someone talking I give 'em just
a little.
Not an aggressive shock.
But just a light shock.
>>Male #2: My name is Pedro Sanchez from Napoleon
Dynamite.
If you vote for me, I'll make sure that everyone
is really quiet in the theater.
>>Male #3: Don't talk during the movies.
Turn off your cell phones and beepers, please.
>>Male #1: If you can find out who they are,
and then go cut their tongue out.
[loud noise]
>>Anderson Cooper: So, I think it's pretty
clear where the Alamo Drafthouse stands on
this issue.
>>Tim: [laughs]
>>Anderson Cooper: And you know what?
Maybe a theater with that kind of policy just
isn't for everyone.
>>Female Customer: You know, I will never
be comin' back to your Alamo Drafthouse or
whatever.
I'd rather go to a regular theater where people
are actually polite.
>>Anderson Cooper: Oh yeah.
The "regularlier" theater are full of polite
people.
Politely shouting at the screen.
Politely bringing screaming toddlers to rated
R movies at 11 o'clock at night.
Politely talking and texting through the whole
movie.
The CEO of the Alamo Drafthouse says he wants
his theater to be different.
Here's Tim League, great American hero.
[laughter]
>>Tim on the Anderson clip: we wanted to take
a hard stand and say that those people are
not welcome at the Alamo Drafthouse.
So we'll get rid of those people and just
make it a better place for the rest of the
movie going public.
>>Anderson Cooper: I think that guy should
win the Nobel Peace Prize.
[laughter]
So listen up, Magnited States.
News Flash.
The movie theater is not your living room
so don't act like it is.
We're paying to see the movie, not your cell
phone light.
And we wanna listen to the actors, not your
lame comments and inane chatter.
Next time you're about to text in a film,
remember the Alamo.
Drafthouse.
Or you might end up at The Ridiculous.
More news ahead in the next hour.
We'll be right back.
[music]
[laughter and applause]
>>Tim: So that was some pretty good press,
I gotta say.
Anyway that was a crazy wild adventure and
that's the last thing that I've got on my
little presentation today.
But you know, if anybody has any questions
about anything please feel free to fire 'em
away.
[audience member asks question off mic]
>>Tim: Well, the girl, uh, we had a lot of
things cued up for those type of Maury Povich
type of shows.
Where they wanted a showdown.
It might have ended up in chairs thrown and
things like that.
Which I would have totally been down for.
But actually it never happened.
The only thing she did was she went onto KVET
in the morning and said that she wanted to
stay anonymous but she was still pretty mad
and pretty feisty on KVET.
And they had a little fun with her and that's
the only appearance she had.
I think she was savvy enough to know that
if she were to come out and be identified
then it would not have been a good thing for
her.
>>Female #1: I agree.
Yeah.
>>Male #1: So, there's been a kind of a lot
of copy cat people who are doing the dinner
and movie type thing.
Studio Movie Grill being one that's kind of
aggressively opening shops across the nation.
Do you see that as a good thing because it's
introducing people to the concept?
And does that make it easier for you to expand?
Or do you think that it's kind of tarnishing
the whole brand of what you're doing?
>>Tim: I'm somewhere in the middle.
It doesn't really matter to me what, we keep
tabs on everybody.
I think it's the never satisfied concept that
we want to know what everybody's doing.
And occasionally we'll say "Oh wow, that's
actually really great.
I wish we would have thought of that."
And then we'll steal that idea.
So, I mean, so you know, like when Flicks
comes into town, we'll you know, our whole
team, we've got logs of information of our
visits to Flicks.
What we like.
What we didn't like.
We've been to Studio Movie Grill a lot of
times.
So I think our role is to try to execute better.
And we're certainly the only type of this
concept that does any type of interesting
programming.
Most of those other concepts are just like
a regular movie theater but they have different
food offerings.
Different concessions offerings.
So more power to 'em.
So we're just, we're gonna expand where we
wanna expand and it doesn't matter what they
do.
>>Male #1: And then one other thing.
In the '90s when I first heard about the Drafthouse,
it was kind of through the ramblings of Harry
Knowles.
Is it just a coincidence that the Drafthouse
and Ain't It Cool News started at the same
time?
Or were you guys kind of in cahoots before
either of those things started?
>>Tim: Uh, it was coincidence.
So, I mean we really did start almost at the
exact same time.
And Harry, along with Rick Linklater who's
in town.
Were both guys that initially when we opened
up were very, very skeptical.
Because for a true cinephile, the idea of
having this added disturbance of food service
in a movie theater is really an offensive
idea.
And so we had to prove to both of those guys.
And Harry, I remember very distinctly the
first movie Harry ever came to was a, we did
a screening of a blaxploitation called "Super
Fly".
Came with a free 40 ounce malt liquor.
It was this crazy
[laughter]
over the top promotion.
And he wrote this long expansive essay about
how much he loved that experience.
And I didn't know who he was.
And somebody had to point out the website
to me and the next time he came in we shook
hands, became friends.
And we've just been, you know we like a lot
of the same movies.
So we actually became businessmen together.
You know.
His site grew at the same time we were growing.
>>Male Presenter: Can someone just walk up?
Or?
Go ahead in the back, Josh.
[audience member asks question of mic]
>>Tim: Mm-hm.
[audience member continues off mic]
>>Tim: it, the working with big licensed brands
has been a, certainly an evolution.
Ah, it's easier now that we're established
and people know what Mondo is.
People actually start coming to us to say,
"Lets, we'd like to do this."
And honestly right, Star Wars was the first
big, big license that we bought.
And it was a big check.
And so writing that check was very speculative.
But it ended up being really great for us.
So it's a little bit frustrating sometimes.
Because there's a lot of the, Star Wars in
particular is very picky about what goes out.
So there's actually a lot of Star Wars designs
that are awesome.
But maybe a little bit outside the wheelhouse
of how they want Star Wars represented.
And so those will never be posters.
They're just conceptual drawings at this point.
So you have to work through that process.
But in general it hasn't been too bad.
The ground rules are laid out that it's Alamo,
it's Mondo basically that's driving the creative
process.
And they don't take input from the studio.
If the studio doesn't like it then they will
scrap it and do something else.
But they're not gonna tweak it to the whims
of the studio.
They are what they are.
They're, they have final cut, I guess, if
you will.
And then the artists, you know, it's Ali Moss
and Tyler Stalter are two of our biggest artists
that we work with.
But Tyler Stalter was unknown.
Like he became famous through the Mondo poster
series.
So because he got a lot more work coming out
of us, he's done stuff for you know Adidas
and Nike and bigger paying jobs than what
we can afford at this point.
But he's always happy to come back.
A, because he's a movie fan, and it's really
satisfying work for him to do.
But also because we've been with him since
the very beginning.
>>Male Presenter: OK.
Two more questions and then.
Tim you pick.
Go ahead.
>>Tim: Uh.
Do, I don't know.
Here we go.
Over.
Right here.
Sorry.
The green shirt.
[audience member speaking off mic]
>>Tim: Oh no.
I keep on telling myself I have to prepare
myself for this question.
[audience member speaking off mic]
>>Tim: Top three movies?
>>Male #2: Top three theater movies.
>>Tim: What are my top three favorite movies?
I'm very, it changes.
It changes a lot.
I just saw the Muppets last week.
So the Muppets is my favorite movie of all
time.
[laughter]
Um.
I really liked it.
I don't know.
I came in.
I hated all those fake trailer ads that they
did.
So I came in with really low expectations
but you know.
I cried in the middle when he's in with all
the portraits.
And I just thought it was like the perfect
mix of nostalgia.
And you know, just, I had a smile on my face.
Um. [soft whistle] I mean I like some sort
of weirdo, obscure movie.
You know.
'Cause I still program Fantastic Fest.
I'm the head of programming.
So what I watch is a lot of foreign genre
films.
There's a, there's a movie you can get on
Amazon actually that's called "Adam's Apples."
Which nobody's seen.
But it's from a Danish director.
It's where Mads Mikkelson got his start, with
this director.
Just this perfect mix of inappropriate comedy
and violence and more inappropriateness and
awkwardness.
I think it's' a great film.
You know, we're, I'll give a unabashed plug
for Drafthouse Films.
You know 'cause we bought, we're buying movies
that we love.
We bought a movie out of the festival this
year called "Bullhead."
Which is from a first time Belgian director.
But it actually, after we bought it, it was
Belgium's choice for Academy Award Best Foreign
Language Film.
It just, it ended up on a variety of short
lists.
So we're, it might be conceivable that this
film ends up being one of the five films for
Best Foreign Language Film for this year.
I don't know.
Fingers crossed.
But it's this crazy story.
Sort of early Scorsese-ish film about a guy
who's addicted to testosterone and runs this
meat processing facility.
And there's this illegal steroids subplot
that goes through it.
And also this very heartfelt, heart crushing
romantic storyline.
So I like a lot of movies like that that are
complicated.
Really well acted.
Story that you haven't seen before.
Fresh and original.
But then I like really stupid movies like
"Teen Lust" is a really, really fun movie
from the '80s that you should probably not
check out.
[laughter]
Shouldn't have said that.
OK.
Next question.
>>Male Presenter: Last question.
>>Tim: In the back.
>>Male #3: I guess mine's following the same
lines as favorite movies except I'm more or
less asking what your favorite worst movies?
I'm a big Mystery Science Theater fan.
I grew up on that stuff.
So I kinda see a lot of similarities in that.
I guess I'll give you an example of mine first.
I loved "Manos: The Hands of Fate"
>>Tim: Yeah.
>>Male #3: And Santa Claus Conquers the Martians.
>>Tim: Those are both very fine films.
Yeah.
"Manos" is apparently getting a restoration
next year.
Yeah, there's one guy that's obsessively doing
it on his own outside of the studio system.
So we might be able to see the ultimate "Manos:
The Hands of Fate" next year.
We'll see.
>>Male #3: As a suggestion, c3333333333333333333333333333333333ould
you just buy all the Mystery Science Theater?
>>Tim: Uh, I'll put it in the idea hopper.
[laughs]
I mean, it's, I am drawn.
Like, I, it's it's tough, because I'm not
such a big fan of the idea of so bad it's
good.
I like to think of those movies as people
that are earnestly trying to make the best
movie possible.
It's just they might have been dropped on
their head as a child.
[laughter]
Or like they just, there's something not quite
right in their makeup.
I really don't' like the movies that are holier
than though.
That they're gonna a willfully make something
campy or bad.
I just, that feels, that rings false to me.
But I do love exactly what you're talking
about.
So some favorites of mine that, strangely
I can answer that question better than my
favorite movies.
I like this movie called "Dangerous Men" by
John Rad.
Who came out, it came out about five years
ago.
But he had been working on it for a decade.
He was a Persian.
Came to the United States.
And apparently made 300 movies in Iran.
Came here and made this action movie in Los
Angeles.
In four-walled theaters in Los Angeles and
it's just this absurd mess.
But very lovable.
I liked "Troll 2".
Which had a documentary about Best Worst Movie.
We were big champions of that film.
There's, I like a lot of '80s straight to
VHS stuff that some of my team knows a lot
better and they've been introducing me to
some of the classics.
But a movie called "Deadly Prey" which is
kinda like a "First Blood" type of movie.
But seemingly shot in somebody's back yard
with this really muscle bound guy in cut off
shorts.
[laughter]
It's pretty good.
So.
This.
We could have a longer conversation about
that if you like.
But I guess that's the last question.
So.
Anyway, I wanna thank you guys for taking
part of your day to hang out.
[applause]
>>Male Presenter: So we have a nice tradition
of being able to offer our speakers for four
hours of time, a eight dollar t-shirt.
>>Tim: Right on.
>>Male Presenter: But it's very special because
it actually identifies you as a speaker here.
>>Tim: Nice.
>>Male Presenter: and there's only like three
people who have this so far.
So.
There you go.
>>Tim: Fantastic.
Thank you.
I will wear it with pride.
>>Male Presenter: Thanks again.
Appreciate that.
>>Tim: Thank you.
[applause]
>>Tim: Thanks guys.